- Bienvenue dans
♪ ♪ ♪
- Lysandre, vous êtes une
de
les plus en vue.
Vous faites de la pop.
♪ C'est le paon impossible
à imaginer ♪
Mais pour vous,
tout a commencé à l'âge de 5 ans
avec vos gammes, avec
de
- Oui!
- C'était par plaisir
ou par devoir?
LYSANDRE,- Par plaisir! Ah, oui,
puis j'achalais ma professeure
de piano; même, je voulais
commencer plus jeune, puis
le monde me disait :
l'année prochaine."
Puis, j'ai des frères et soeurs
qui ont fait du piano aussi,
donc je les accompagnais.
Je
Apparemment, ça venait de moi.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Vous êtes bardée de diplômes,
vous avez faits des études
à Vincent-d'Indy, au
conservatoire, uiuiuiuiuiuiuiuir
aussi votre maîtrise au Royal
Academy of Music de Londres.
Donc vous avez baignée dans
le classiq l l l l l l l l l l ,
vous vous enlignez dans la pop.
Pourquoi la pop?
- Je pense que c'étaitbababababi
cette espèce de rigidité puis de
discipline, pour avoir une scène
plus de codes, où est-ce qu
n'y avait plus vraiment de
mes propres règles aussi,
puis très... un endroit où est-
un petit peu plus libre.
♪ L'histoire oubliéebububububube
"Sans Oublier". Vous parlez
de la mémoire; la mémoire,
c'est important pour vous,
c'est l'objet de ve e e e e e e.
Vous avez eu une importante
commotion cérébrale en 2019,
où vous avez... justement, vous
craignieouououououououououououox
de musique classique ass
complexes. C'est une crainte
qui vous habite, ça? Evovovovov?
Parce que la mémoire
une musicienne, c'est tout,
dans le fond!cococococococococo,
pusi quand tu te retrouves
dans un examen où est-ce que
tu ne sais même plus où tu es
parce qucececececececececececece
où est-ce qu'on ne comprend
plus rien, c'est extrêmement
effrayant. Et puis ça a faittets
plus monter sur scène du tout.ae
l'anxiété de performance,finalee
que j'ai découvert en faisant...
en étant suivie par
Et donc, d'écrire là-dessus m'a
aussi permis de passer à travers
et de me dire que, bien, que n s
ma vocation d'apprendre des
concertos classiques de mémoire,
capable d'apprendre plein
d'autres choses, mes mots.
qui m'était destiné fina
♪ Toutes les femmes
sont des reines ♪
- Sur votre nouvel album,
il y a des effluves de
de Radiohead et de Beatles
version Sgt. Pepper's.
- Non, absolument pas.
Les "Tintagel"eeeeeeee
un... quasiment, on voulait
faire une espèce d'ode, de
une espèce de... on niaise,
mais cèèèèèèèèce
de "Hey Jude" contemporain
où est-ce qu'on renversaitarara,
ce n'est plus le même, où est-c
qu'on parle de la sororité, puis
où est-ce qu'on élève les fem
- On parle de la chanson
"Tintagel".
- "Tintagel", oui, exactemen
exactement.
- Et c'est sur cette chanson-là
que vous chantez aussi,
le refrain : "Toutes les femmes
sont des reines."
- Oui.
- Puis ça, ça a été inspirér r n
de l'été 2020, où vous composiez
emememememememememememememememes
Beatles inspirent la musique,
mais pour les paroles, comment
la vague de dénonciation
- Bien, c'est parce
qu'entre nous, entre femme
entre soeurs, on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait des histoires
de se confier, d'avoir
des témoignages
à entendre, ça a fait en sorte
qu'il y avait comme une
très sécurisant où est-ce que
moi, je meuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuis
beaucoup de mes amies aussi,
puis j
honneur à ça, finalement.
- Jetrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtre disque
vinyle parce que vous avez une
ve
album. Il est absolument
NoNoNoNoNoNoNoNoNoNon seulement
il y a cette affiche avec les
on voit rarement ça, et même cÊs
une passionnée de vinyles?
J'ai reçu les collections depppu
d'autres collections de vinyles
je collect
les vinyles un peu. J'ai comme,n
tranqu
Je pense que le geste delllllllt
beuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuis c'est
encapsulé là-dedans, et donceset
album-là, "Sans Oublier".aiaiai.
Merci beaucoup.cicicicicicicici.
♪ Sans cette obsolescence ♪
♪ Mdadadadadadadadadadadadadada♪
♪ Suis-moi, je sais marcher ♪